I like to dialogue with my mind now that
sounds quite funny to say that you have
a dialogue and a conversation with your
mind but anybody that does deep work
with their mind whether through
meditation whether through mind power is
that you find is that your mind is
talking to you all the time it's telling
you things it's commenting it's too cold
today or I don't like the people that
I'm with or I wish I had more money or
isn't this a delicious meal so your mind
is constantly commenting and has a
narrative and is thinking all the time
and it's very valuable to first of all
know that and observe it because one of
the very first teachings that I give is
that you are not your mind and to
realize that you're not your mind that
your mind is a part of you and a very
important part of you a very valuable
part of you but it's only a part of you
you are much Beyond simply your mind and
your mind talks to you all the time you
get to talk to your mind as well need
motivation watch your top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because when I
started my first business I really
struggled to believe myself I was making
300 bucks a month and quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
listen from one of the best John Kehoe
and my take on his top 10 was a success
enjoy
good
sometimes at night and this is quite
often when I do it lying in bed and I'm
thinking thoughts and and I'll just stop
and I'll ask my mind I'll say
what do you want to think about right
now
and the mind is kind of goes oh
it feels seen it feels noticed it it it
it it feels actually a little bit
vulnerable it's like what do you mean
what do I want to think about well what
what would you like to think about
and the mind might say
I want to think about how upset I am
about some and it named some person an
incident that happened maybe a few days
ago or a week ago I want to think about
how terrible this person is
and you go okay you have that option but
can I give another suggestion to you
why don't you have compassion for this
person
why don't we
you and your mind why don't we have
compassion would you be willing to have
compassion for this person the mind says
no I don't want to have compassion and I
want to feel really angry
and you can say to the mind okay then
um you can be angry and and but you know
what how's that going to make us feel
why don't you be angry for let's be
angry for a couple minutes
and your mind gets really angry for a
couple minutes and then you go now how
does that make us feel
the mind says I I I'm angry I'm upset I
I well do we like this feeling no we
don't like this feeling
let's try compassion for this person
let's realize that maybe this person is
wounded internally maybe they're going
through a lot of problems and
difficulties and let's try compassion
let's do that for the next two minutes
and the mind says okay let's have
compassion for that person
and you have compassion for that person
for two minutes
and then you say to the mind how does
that feel
and the mind goes that feels much better
all right then here's what we're going
to do is I will let you think what you
want to think sometimes
and you let me think what we want to
think
and I have different things for example
um it's been a long day today I think
that I would like to feel gratitude
right now
can we feel gratitude together do we
have anything to be uh thankful for in
our life the mind will say well let me
think
and it will come up for reasons on why
to be thankful
and you move into gratitude
and so that's exactly
how you work with the mind at different
times when it could be maybe maybe you
know when you're when you're doing your
meditation or or throughout the day to
take out
I mean we take coffee breaks why not
take a mind break
why not take a break through your day
several times through your day
where the mind will think what you
wanted to think and you can work with
love
you can work with inner peace you can
work with gratitude you can work with
success you can work with faith I mean
there's so many ways that you can work
with the mind and get it to meditate and
contemplate or you can work with worry
you can work with fear you can work with
anger you can work with resentment
all these are possibilities
and the mind has a whole range of things
that it can think about
so the first thing is to be aware
that your mind is thinking all the time
and secondly
your mind is not you
you're separate from your mind your mind
is only a part of you you have the
ability and actually the responsibility
to dialogue with the mind
and to guide the mind and to train the
mind and instruct the mind and what I
found with the mind is the Mind loves to
be trained
the mind doesn't like to be out of
control the mind doesn't like to be fear
and worry it just it falls into that
trap and it falls into that trap because
it doesn't have you guiding it
but when you can enter into dialogue and
guide your mind your mind will become
your best friend your absolute best
friend your biggest supporter
and you'll be quite a team together rule
number two is practice happiness in life
we want to prioritize what is important
to us
and there are so many things that we
want in life
we want money we want
relationships we want Health we want
interesting experiences and the list of
goals that we have in our life can be
quite long and they can change from from
period to period in our life obviously
the things that you want in your 20s
aren't going to be the same thing that
you want in your 50s and so in life it
is a constant uh Pursuit
of achieving goals and getting the
things that we want out of life
but there is one thing that is a
constant
and that constant is
we want to be happy
and everybody wants to be happy and we
want life to be simple we want it to be
easy we want it to be effortless
and we want to enjoy ourselves each and
every day
now I discovered many many years ago
that there are practices
that allow you to be happy in fact I
wrote a book called the practice of
Happiness now notice that the book is
not called the pursuit of happiness
happiness is not something we pursue
it is the practice of happiness
and so what you do is you practice
being happy
now one of the things about happiness is
that there's a misconception that
happiness is something that you achieve
and is something that is permanent and
once you've achieved it you forever have
it
and I think that rather than look at the
word happiness we need to change it a
little bit
and so rather than thinking of happiness
why don't we think of contentment
can I be content in my life
can I be at peace in my life
can I be
relaxed in my life
and can I practice these things day by
day
and what you'll find is that if indeed
happiness is the ultimate goal and and
truly it is
then what you do is that you practice
every day
having what I call moments of happiness
like this very moment you can be at
peace with what's happening in your life
now there might be many things in your
life that are troubling
yet at the same time there are many
things in your life that bring you Joy
that bring you pleasure your children
your friends a piece of music
something that you read maybe maybe this
very moment just listening to me
is is calming is relaxing is insightful
and and something is being triggered
inside you where you realize
this very moment I'm at peace
and so what you do is you take on the
practices of happiness
and you you take on the practice of
loving kindness
and spending time just loving other
people or doing kind things generosity
and what you notice that when you do
these things is that you feel fulfilled
you feel joyful you feel relaxed
and so it doesn't have to be complicated
and that's what happens a lot of times
is in our life is that we make it too
complicated
now one of the things that you learn in
the mind power training and the master
class is that you learn that the mind is
a storyteller that the mind tells us
stories that the mind has narratives
about everything in our life
so here's a story and here's a narrative
that you can begin to tell yourself
life is simple
life is easy
life happens to me Moment by moment
you can even have that as an affirmation
life is simple
life is easy
life is something that happens to me
Moment by moment
and as you take on that affirmation as
you take on that narrative as you tell
yourself this over and over again
guess what
life will become simple
life will become easy and life will
unfold Moment by moment and of course
that's the way it works
so don't over complicate it
that what you do is very simply
embrace your life
each day as a separate unique day that
is an amazing journey a journey that you
will never ever experience again
and you appreciate it and you look for
things to be joyful about
and you stop and you allow inner peace
to enter into you
and you look for ways to be kind for
other people and you notice that when
I'm kind with other people when when I'm
when I compliment them or maybe help
them in some way you notice how good
this makes me feel
and then you realize I should do this
more often
and you do it more often and you take on
these practices and as you take on these
practices of living life
Moment by moment experience by
Experience day by day
you realize that the real treasure in
life
is inner peace
contentment
loving kindness
and you can do these things each and
every day
this is the journey and path to
happiness and a happy and successful
life rule number three is follow your
calling you don't find your purpose in
life
your purpose in life finds you and it
happens by you being an authentic human
being and following what feels right to
you
and following your passion because each
of us has a purpose and a meaning in
life
and usually that purpose and meaning is
tied into what you love to do
the universe wants you to be successful
and the universe needs you to be
successful because you are part of the
universe
and each one of us has special gifts and
special talents and a special way of
contributing to our world unfolding and
to Bringing goodness into the world
and bringing goodness into the world is
what we should be thinking about
if we are authentic
to who we are and we follow our call
then our purpose will find us
now if what I'm saying is true that each
of us does have a purpose in life and
that the universe is calling us to
fulfill our purpose
then probably it's tied up into
something that you love to do
for example procreation is having sex is
pleasurable because the species needs to
propagate and because it's fun because
it's pleasurable we do it and we end up
with babies and that's how the
population increases
so if the universe wants you to
contribute something valuable
why would it give you something that is
uncomfortable or why would it give you
something that you don't feel in
alignment with of course it's going to
give you something that you love to do
because then you will do it
so the first thing to understand
is trust what feels right
and follow your passion and be prepared
to bring goodness into the world and
this is what is taught in all our
spiritual traditions
for example in the Jewish Kabbalah which
I have studied and practiced what they
teach is that each Soul has a purpose in
their life
but no soul will ever know or understand
the total meaning of life
but what you are called to do is to
discover
your purpose in life and to fulfill it
your little piece of what needs to be
done and in the Christian tradition it
is the same way in the in the Christian
tradition they're called the gifts of
the Spirit and there are many gifts of
the Spirit and no one person has all the
gifts each of us has a little peace that
we add
and the Buddhist
in the Buddhist tradition what we are
called our purpose is twofold number one
to awaken ourselves and become
enlightened
and number two to bring goodness into
the world
[Music]
a lot of Courage
to follow your uniqueness and follow
your calling but if you can understand
that deep within you there is something
calling to you to be your best to be
your best self to bring goodness into
the world and that you do have gifts and
talents
then you follow it wherever it leads
many years ago I was very fortunate that
I discovered the compass that guidance
did me perfectly in my life
and it was that I realized what I really
needed to do is to follow what was fun
and interesting
and I followed what was fun and
interesting
and that led me into going into the
woods it led me into developing my
teaching about Consciousness and the
powers of the Mind
and you can too you have a purpose
you have a meaning
but you don't have to know it all at
once
trust what's calling you and be a good
person sometimes your purpose happens
through a tragedy candy Lightner who
founded mad
m-a-d-d Mothers Against Drunk Driving
that happened because her daughter was
killed in a car accident by a drunk
driver and she was so outraged that she
did something to make a difference
and she founded Mothers Against Drunk
Driving which is now also Mothers
Against distracted driving
maybe it's a tragedy
maybe it's a calling you feel Within
maybe it's a very simple thing like
trying to do goodness and bringing
goodness into the world in each and
every day it doesn't mean we have to be
like Martin Luther King or Nelson
Mandela or Gandhi or have some great
vision it simply means that we trust
ourselves we trust that in conscious
evolution and those of you that follow
my teachings know that I firmly believe
that Consciousness is evolving
and that you are a part of that evolving
consciousness
and if we trust that
then all we have to do is be our best
self each and every day
so
how do you find your purpose in life
no it's the other way around
your purpose finds you and it finds you
by being authentic
and living your life day by day
following what feels right bringing
goodness into the world
and that will reveal your purpose rule
number four is be in charge of your
emotions it's not okay to feel negative
about yourself all the time it's not
okay to be angry all the time hey
something happens and it really upsets
you get angry be angry
and then let go of it the worst thing
that you can do is just hang on to it
within you
so what you do with with what we call
anger and hate and resentment and and
jealousy is rather than trying to
eliminate them entirely
allow them a very brief
now I'm saying very brief time with you
and while you're feeling them notice how
you feel
and what you're going to find as you
become proficient with this you're going
to find this does not make me feel very
good in fact when I come out of it I'm
feeling really negative I'm feeling
really drained aha
what a great revelation
these things make me feel negative and
drained so the next question
why would you want to indulge in them
and and then you realize I don't want to
indulge in them and so what you do is
you become a choreographer of your own
energy
that yes you can allow yourself to be
depressed or angry or resentful or
jealous or whatever you can allow that
to happen you don't have to forbid it
but then you notice no it's almost
always counterproductive so maybe I'll
give it a minute I'll be angry for a
minute or I'll be jealous for a minute
and then let go of it and then just work
on love work on success vibration work
on acknowledging yourself and feeling
good about yourself acknowledging other
people work with that energy and that's
a very good strategy also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building them momentum
in your life and your business I'll see
you there rule number five is set the
right goals all of us are different
every single one of us is unique and
every single one of us has
a destiny every one of us has a purpose
and meaning to our life
so the first thing you want to look at
is what are the societal uh means what
are our cultural means that tell us what
is a successful life and what they are
are that you make a lot of money that
you're rich that you're famous that your
good looking that you're young I mean
these are all the things that uh our
cult what I call the cultural memes
so what will happen is that these will
pull you towards them because it's what
you see on your your internet feed it's
what you see on TV it's what you see in
magazines it's what people are talking
about so you have to distinguish is this
my calling as well
and there may be some of them that are
your calling I mean there's nothing
wrong with with being financially
independent and and having a successful
life all those are very good things
but beyond that
what is it that is calling me what is it
that that
my life wants to be and the only way
that you can approach that is
what would I love to do what what is it
that I really feel that I'm good at
because the universe wants you to be
successful it wants all of us to be
successful that success is ingrained in
every single cell in our body it is
wired in our Consciousness and and so
because we're wired for success and each
one of us is seated with different
talents different desires
then if the universe wants you to be
successful and I'm talking personally
you not Society but if it wants you to
be successful
then
obviously it's going to imprint
something that you would love to do
because why would it give you something
that you don't enjoy why would it give
you something that is difficult it wants
you to be successful in order for you to
be successful it has to encourage you
and the way it does that is it's
something that you love to do
so what I suggest to my students always
is to reevaluate the goals that you have
at different times of your life
obviously goals that you have at 20 are
no longer appropriate of 40 are no
longer the goals at 40 are no longer
appropriate at 60. but that's the easy
part sometimes the goals that you've
established last month
are no longer appropriate because
something new has happened to you you've
had a new insight you've had a deeper
understanding a new opportunity has
revealed itself to you
so the way that you approach it in your
life is first of all you're never going
to get it a hundred percent right and
that's okay because often when we go off
on uh the wrong path when we trust
ourselves that will reveal itself
because maybe a couple weeks into it or
a couple months into it you'll say to
yourself This doesn't feel right
and again you're connected to your
subconscious mind
one of your beliefs that you can imprint
into your subconscious is that I always
make the right decisions
and so what that will mean is that when
you don't make a right decision you will
feel it really quickly you'll feel it
within a week or two that no this isn't
quite right and rather than being
disappointed that you made the wrong
decision think of it as like sailing
now I I love to sail and uh when you go
out sailing you have to set your sales
according to where the wind is coming
from and you need to tack back and forth
to get to your destination it's never a
straight line
a motorboat is a straight line but with
sailboats you're going back and forth
tacking either with the wind or Against
the Wind and that's exactly how it is in
life is Destiny is never a straight line
never
it's it it meanders it goes in different
directions
sometimes it goes backwards sometimes
you make mistakes uh sometimes you make
wrong decisions that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that in fact it's the
way life unfolds so always you come back
to does this feel right does it feel
right to me and as I'm achieving the
different objectives in this particular
goal that I have chosen for myself as I
achieve them how do I feel do I feel
great do I feel yes I'm on the right
track or do I feel you know what I
achieved it but it still doesn't feel
right
trust what feels right always trust what
feels right because how you make
decisions in your life is with your
logic
and with your feeling now the logic is
the conscious mind your feeling is your
subconscious and so when the logic and
you're feeling your intuition tell you
the same thing then you know absolutely
you're on the right track
but when the logic says one thing and
you're feeling an intuition says
something else
it's my experience that I always go with
my feeling and intuition because almost
always that is the more accurate one
so
have fun in your life
be successful in your life
make decisions that feel right and when
they no longer feel right drop them and
move on to something else and when you
follow that pattern you will be led very
well you your destiny will find you and
you will have a fun and interesting and
successful life rule number six is
navigate changes in life life demands
change and we forget that we we get too
comfortable in our life and we think oh
I don't want especially when
everything's going well we never make a
change when everything's going well
because we're comfortable with it
but when a crisis comes it forces you to
make changes because you just can't
allow the crisis to overcome you and
very often when you make those changes
they are the exact changes that you
needed to make to grow in your life to
become a better person a smarter person
a more successful person and on a
microcosm
each one of us needs to make changes in
our life I mean change only happens by
choice chance or crises and and hey
we've got a crisis so don't let it go to
waste uh see what is this calling me to
do and from an individual point of view
that's the advantage but I want to even
speak right now from a macro view from a
Humanity point of view
this crisis is an opportunity too
it's an opportunity for us as a species
to say are we really living our best
selves how can we as a community how can
we as as a population
have different priorities
and I think the number one priority that
any of us can ever have is to be our
best selves
I mean forget about how much money I can
make or how many cars I can have or
whether I live in a mansion or or how
successful I can make my business now
I'm not negating these things these
things are can be important to you and
but
have we focused on what would make me a
better person
what would make me Kinder what would
make me more compassionate what would
make me more loving how can I give back
to my community maybe we've forgotten
those things
and if we've forgotten them then what a
great opportunity for a crisis to make
us re-examine them so a crisis forces
change and change is almost always good
even if we resist it rule number seven
is thrive in a crisis so the first thing
is to acknowledge that yes I am in a
crisis
the second thing to do is to acknowledge
that I have been in a crisis before
and think about it
you know usually we forget about the
crisis I mean crises are are never
enjoyable they are traumatic they're
hard they they tax us to the limits they
they draw upon all our resources there's
absolutely nothing Pleasant about a
crisis
but we do get through them
so if you're of a certain age and you
know if you're at least 30 you've
probably had at least one or two crises
if you're 50 you've had at least three
or four and I'm in my 70s I've had about
six or seven major crises
and what happens
you get through them
so that's the second thing that I want
you to do is I want you to remember that
you have been here before no not this
particular crisis
but a different crisis
and you did manage it now at the time
you had no idea I want you just to
reflect back on previous crisis it might
have been a a Health crisis or it might
have been a marriage breakup or it might
have been a bankruptcy or any number of
crises that you went through and at the
time you had no idea how you were going
to get through it in fact you thought it
was hopeless be honest with me you
really did didn't you and why I'm
sharing that with you is because when I
went through my crisis even with my mind
Powers I mean I thought how am I ever
going to get out of this
but then I had to realign myself and
remind myself that no you always get out
of Crisis always
and so what I would like to do is to
change the narrative
now the mind is a storyteller
the Mind likes to tell us stories
and and your mind right now has a story
about this crisis
and the story might be I'm never going
to get out of it I don't know how I'm in
a mess my finances are in a mess I've
lost my job or I'm losing my job uh I I
I don't know how I'm going to pay the
mortgage or rent I don't know how I'm
going to do that and for many of us that
is the story that we have going through
us
so what I'd like to do is I'd like to
change I call this it's actually an
advanced mind power technique I'm I'm
I'm sharing with you some Advanced
Techniques why because they're called
for right now that's why
and an advanced mind power technique is
taking control of the narrative
and how we take control of the narrative
is that we observe what we're thinking
right now
am I thinking right now that I'm not
going to survive this that this is a
disaster that I don't know how I'm going
to get out of it that I'm never going to
you know rebound from that if that's the
narrative what you do is you notice it
you notice okay isn't that interesting
how I'm thinking
and you change the narrative this is the
first thing that you want to do in your
mind power practice is you want to
change the narrative
and you change the narrative by saying
to yourself
that this crisis is hard
it's difficult
it's taxing me to my limit
and no I don't know how it's going to
all work out and no I don't know
how I'm going to rebound from it
but what I do know
is that I will rebound from it
what I do know
is that it will bring an opportunity to
me
what I do know
is that I will develop courage
resilience
creativity
that this will bring out the Best in Me
and that becomes your new narrative
and it becomes your new narrative
because you tell it to yourself
every morning when you wake up
the very first thing that you say to
yourself when you wake up is
this crisis
will make me a better person
I will not only survive this crisis
I will thrive
I will become a better person
I will become stronger I will become
more resilient I will become more
creative I will develop new work habits
I will be develop new mind power habits
that I will become a better person from
this crisis
and when you fall off to sleep
you spend five minutes
and you remind yourself once again
that I am going to come out of this
crisis a better person
and you spend five minutes telling
yourself this story
creating the narrative
and what happens with taking control of
the narrative and you're getting an
advanced mind power technique right now
is that what you're doing is you're
taking control of what your mind is
going to think
so
if you do this
every day in the morning for five
minutes and every day in the evening for
five minutes
then what will happen is you will come
and start to believe
that you are going to come out of this
better rule number eight is stop
negative thinking negative serve no
purpose for us and yet it makes
absolutely no difference to the Mind
whether you think constructive thoughts
or destructive thoughts it makes no
difference to the mind
it makes all the difference to us
it makes all the difference to our life
it makes all the difference to the
things that are going to happen to us
but it makes no difference to the mind
now notice I'm speaking of you and your
mind as if they're different
and they are different
now I'm going to share with you
something very important to understand
and that is that you are not your mind
just like you're not your hand
your hand is a part of who you are and
you're not your foot and your your foot
is a part of who you are and you're not
your mind your mind is simply a part of
who you are it's not you
in the mind power training uh one of the
names that I give to the conscious mind
is the great Trickster
and the reason that I call it this is
because our mind tricks us all the time
it limits us it fools us it brings us
negative thoughts and if we think that
we're our mind then we have to listen to
every single thought that happens
but we're not our mind
so what we want to do is we want to
eliminate negative thinking from our
mind
now there are four excellent techniques
for eliminating negatives from the mind
and I want to share two of them with you
right now
the first technique is called cut it off
and in the cut it off technique what we
do is the instant that we find ourselves
thinking a negative thought we just
immediately cut it off and insert a
totally different thought into our mind
we don't argue with it we don't analyze
it we don't defend ourselves against it
we just cut it off
and the key in this technique is the
instant that you're thinking a negative
thought like maybe the negative thought
comes to you oh you're worthless nothing
much is going to happen to you and you
find yourself thinking that you go oh
wait that's a negative thought just cut
it off and insert a totally different
thought
now in the second technique is totally
different instead of cutting it off what
we do is we label it
we say to ourself what is happening
inside me is I am now experiencing
quotation marks and negative thought it
has no more power over us than what we
give it
and here I'm going to share with you
something that when you understand this
next truth you are 75 of the way of
eliminating all negatives from your mind
just by understanding this next truth
and that is that negatives only have
power over you if you react to them if
we fail to react to the negative it has
no power
for example when you're thinking a
negative thought and you go oh my God
what's going to happen I just know
that's going to happen maybe the thought
is oh you're never going to get ahead
financially and you start thinking about
that that's true it's not and and it
builds upon itself and it is getting its
power from you
negatives are like psychic leeches they
get their power from us
so in the second technique what we do is
we simply remind ourselves it's only a
negative thought it's only a negative
thought and you realize wait
it's only a negative thought that takes
the power away from it
I mean wouldn't it be great if when
negatives came they came like with a
little light that flashed to warn us or
maybe a little warning sound like
you're about to hear a negative thought
you can choose to believe it or not I
mean wouldn't that be great if that's
the way they came
but it's not when negatives come they
come like the voice of God guess what's
going to happen to you they come with
such Authority and of course because we
don't know that we're not our mind we
have to sit there and listen to it
you know from this point on you don't
have to do that
in the six laws of the Mind the fourth
law is the law of control
and it states that we are forever
experiencing thoughts but we have the
power and the ability to either
entertain these thoughts or dismiss them
we control our thoughts
so the next time you find yourself
thinking negatively why don't you try
one of these techniques and see how well
they work
no longer do we have to be overwhelmed
with negatives no longer do they have
power over us from this point on we have
the techniques to eliminate negatives
from our mind
so go out and use them rule number nine
is overcome fear first of all let's have
a look at what exactly is a fear
a fear is you imagining in your mind
what you don't want to have happen to
you
now why would you ever do that
well you do it because the mind is lazy
and we do it because we don't we we
aren't even conscious of the fact
that we are feeling fear and thinking
fear and it it just overtakes us
and this is where the student of Mind
Powers has a distinct advantage over
someone that does not understand how
their thoughts work is that you
understand that what a fear is is
it's a group of thoughts it's you
imagining what you don't want to have
happen to you it's like using mind power
in reverse
now why would you do that
you do it because the mind just
naturally makes up stories about the
different aspects that we have in our
life and if we aren't training regularly
if we aren't in the habit of working
with mind power and feeding our mind
positive thoughts and having positive
beliefs then fears naturally enter into
it
but here's a secret that I want you to
really know and understand
and you will have great success when you
understand this
is where do fears get their power from
fears get their power from you
they get their power from you thinking
them over and over again it is you that
is adding fuel to the fire
and actually that's a very good analogy
because when you have a fire whether
it's a house burning down or whether
it's a forest fire and all the trees are
burning down what a fire needs is it
needs two things
it needs fuel
and it needs oxygen
well when we have fears it too needs
fuel and it needs oxygen so what is the
fuel in our fears well maybe it is the
actual fear of losing your job or not
getting ahead or falling sick or
whatever whatever the fear is that you
have that's the fuel
but what the oxygen is
is you thinking it you focusing on it
you are giving it fuel you are giving it
energy
so here's the strategies for eliminating
fears and they're deceptively simple but
very very powerful
first of all whatever it is that you're
fearing
make a notice of it
be conscious of it and say I am not
going to allow my mind to think that
anymore
and so what I'm going to do is every
time that I think this fear and feel
this fear
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
two minutes of affirmations
affirming the exact opposite of what the
fear is suggesting
so if the fear is uh I'm going to lose
my job I'm going to be broke you catch
yourself and you say okay I'm going to
do two minutes of affirmation saying to
myself I'm going to be really successful
I'm going to be prosperous I'm going to
have lots of money I have no worries
about finances and you repeat this to
yourself over and over again for two
minutes and when I say two minutes I
mean that you're actually either on your
watch or on on your phone you've
actually set a time and you do it for
two minutes
now here's what's going to happen is the
fear is going to go yeah right as if
that's going to make a difference
and that fear will come right back
what do you do you hit it with two
minutes of affirmations over and over
and over again affirming the exact
opposite of what the fear is suggesting
and then what will happen is the fear
will go oh he or she they're really
serious about this uh I better not come
back now for about three hours
but it'll come back it'll test you what
do you do you hit it again with two
minutes of affirmation so I'm going to
be tremendously successful I'm going to
have lots of money or I'm going to be
really healthy and so what you are is
you are
counteracting what the fear is
suggesting to you
now this is very very powerful it's very
powerful in two ways number one you are
creating a new thought habit
and secondly you're taking the power
away from that fear
so always remember that fear gets its
energy from you
so that everything that you can do to
stop focusing on it
and to create new images new imprints
through visualizations and affirmations
that will quite logically eliminate the
fear and it by the way it is your
responsibility to eliminate fears fears
exist in you
and you can think them or you can
eliminate them you are in control of
your mind angle number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
trust Life Trust in life means that you
surrender into the mystery of it
and in surrendering into the mystery of
it
means that you have faith
that all things will work out
if you trust and you act on what feels
right to you
um
notice in your past the way I like to
approach it is to notice in the past
when often we've had Misfortune or we've
had a tragedy
or we've had a failure and at the time
it seemed absolutely disastrous we had
no idea how it was going to work out
what Solutions what was going to happen
to us
and yet somehow
it all did work out
and often it works out even better for
us
and if we can embrace the concept
that life wants us to be successful
and that we are part of the universe
and that we are connected to everything
and by the way these are all quantum
physics truths that we are connected to
everything
that we are one with everything I love
how quantum physics and and spirituality
the how how the teachings of our
religions and the teachings of quantum
physics are all connected
that if this is true and it obviously is
true
then everything that happens to us
has a purpose a meaning or it's a path
to something else
and again we also Embrace that life is
not perfect
and so what we do is that we accept
whatever happens to us we don't
necessarily have to fight it
that whatever it is whatever Misfortune
we're we're presently experiencing it's
ours it's ours to deal with
and so we surrender into that
but we surrender into faith
and we Act
it doesn't mean that you just surrender
and you do nothing
you first of all it's a it's a two-step
process
you surrender into faith
that all is happening in my life as it
should
that this Misfortune this problem that I
have is here for me to deal with
and that I will deal with it and it's
going to bring a positive outcome to me
because what I'm going to do is I'm
going to build my courage and resilience
through this
I am now going to execute
on my actions
and it means you change your thoughts
you change your beliefs and you do
whatever is necessary to change that
circumstance
the power of action cannot be over
emphasized and the action is trust faith
and action
doing whatever is necessary to change
the situation into something positive
our subconscious is connected to
everything
and this lets us work with our
subconscious and very creative and
innovative ways
let me share with you an example of how
an individual used the powers of their
subconscious
in the 1990s early 1990s out of work
actor Jim Carrey used the power of a
subconscious mind to become the famous
and successful movie star that he is now
and he did it by writing himself a check
what he did is as a symbol to himself he
took out his checkbook and he wrote a
check for 10 million dollars and he
signed it and he said for services
rendered and he put it into his wallet
and then what he would do is every day
he would take out that check and he
would look at it but he wouldn't just
look at it he would imagine himself
receiving this money for a movie and he
did this over and over again every day
he would do this and not only that but
he would say to himself I'm a fabulous
actor everybody wants to work with me I
have lots of movie offers now this
wasn't true he wasn't hardly getting any
offers at all
but by doing this over and over again he
was imprinting directly into his
subconscious
and then what happened is opportunities
started opening up
and then five years later he received
the check for 10 million dollars
starring in the movie Dumb and Dumber
now you have to understand this in the
context of who Jim Carrey was his talent
as an actor his comic genius his work
ethic his determination to succeed and
the nature of the entertainment business
all these played a part in his success
but what is undisputable is by
programming his subconscious mind in
this way
he began attracting new agents producers
scripts and opportunities that made him
the success that he is
and that's exactly what you will do when
you harness the powers of your
subconscious mind you will attract the
opportunities you need to be
tremendously successful
work
simply imagining something in your mind
and repeating it to yourself over and
over again how can that make it happen
well it's simple
everything is vibrations of energy
everything
buildings are vibrations of energy
I'm a vibration of energy you're a
vibration of energy our thoughts are
vibrations of energy
now it appears that buildings are
different from trees and I'm different
from My Wife and you are different from
their friends and on one level that's
true and obvious
but on a Quantum level on a subatomic
level
everything is vibrating energy and
everything is in communication with each
other in the vibrating web of all
reality
and help us understand this just think
of algorithms in computer programming
for example uh you might Google search a
vacation in Greece
and then what you notice is for the next
couple weeks you're getting
advertisements for playing tickets and
hotel offers because the algorithms know
that you're interested in Greece
now listen to this
the universe is forever monitoring and
responding to the energy of Who You Are
and what you want to do is learn to
speak the secret language of the
universe and yes there is a secret
language of the universe
and that secret language is vibrations
everything is vibrating energy
everything
I have a John Kehoe vibration of energy
and it brings me my John Kehoe reality
you have a vibration of energy science
calls it your energy signature
everything has an energy signature
everything has a vibration of energy
earning 10 million dollars for a movie
is a vibration of energy
success is a vibration of energy and all
your goals everything that you want to
happen in your life has a specific
vibration of energy
and so what we do is we begin to align
with this vibration of energy
now here's a little trick
whatever it is that you want to have
happen to you what you do is you imagine
in your mind that it already has
happened to you not that it will happen
not that you're very confident and
determined
but that it already has happened
now I'm not talking about living an
illusion and hanging on to this for all
day I'm talking about an exercise that
takes maybe two or three minutes and
during that two or three minutes what
you do is you imagine that you already
have it
and what that is doing is that is
imprinting into your subconscious that
vibration of energy
and when that vibration of energy is in
your subconscious it attracts the people
the circumstances the events the
synchronicity that makes it happen
I mean it's extraordinary
we get to imprint into our subconscious
whatever it is that we want
let your subconscious do the work for
you all you have to do is instruct it
very clearly on what you want to have
happen imagine it in your mind as if it
already has happened and repeat this
over and over and over again
and it will find its way in the
subconscious and then the subconscious
does the work for you imagine if your
subconscious was working for you 24
hours a day each and every day and
that's what it will do
our subconscious is our partner in
success and all we have to do is connect
with it
you know even spending five minutes a
day you can connect with your
subconscious imprint into it and have
extraordinary things happen to you
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Consciousness is
creating your reality if you put a
picture of fear into your reality then
your biology Behavior will manifest
things to be afraid of because this is a
short statement but to me it's the most
powerful one